all right hi everybody uh my name is
tyler starr
and i am a postdoctoral fellow in the
lab of jesse bloom
at the fred hutchinson cancer research
center in seattle washington
and today i'm going to tell you about a
project that we recently completed
uh on the deputational scanning of the
sars kobe 2 receptor binding domain
and so before i get into that i wanted
to start with thanking a lot of the key
people who also contributed to this
project
as i mentioned jesse bloom is my advisor
and then this work was done
in close collaboration with ali greeney
a graduate student in the lab
and then beyond that we had help from a
couple professors of biochemistry at
university of washington
neil kaine who's a structural biologist
and protein designer
as well as david wiesler who is a
structural biologist who
has actually studied chronoviruses for
more than the last six months or so
um and i also wanted to point out that
everything i'm going to talk about today
was recently published in this
publication here
and so i'm not going to go into all the
details but i invite anybody to check
out this publication if you want
to hear more all right so um as you can
tell from the title um that we're going
to tell you about today is focused on
sars kobe 2
which is this virus renders here on the
left side of the screen
and a particularly striking or notable
feature of this virus
is its surface glycoprotein which is
called spike
and so this is the protein that
decorates the outer surface of
this virus and enables it with key
functional properties
um the main focus of the talk today is
on a particular domain
of this spike protein which is called
the receptor binding domain
or the rbd and so the receptor binding
domain is the small portion
of the spike protein that sits sort of
buried
in this kind of occluded conformation
while the virus is
normally circulating but it
stochastically samples an open
conformation
through just normal protein dynamics and
when it's in this open conformation
um it exposes a surface um a contact
surface which
confers specificity to binding uh for
this ace2 receptor
so the h2 receptor is the protein on
host target cells
that the virus binds to and that sets
off
you know a chain reaction of
conformational changes which eventually
allow
the virus to enter the cell and initiate
cellular infection
and so because of sort of the key
importance of this receptor binding
domain
interaction with h2 we really wanted to
get
more insight into how the rbd or this
receptor binding domain
functions and confers specificity for
ace2
this rbd ace2 interaction has a lot of
interesting evolutionary
and immunological consequences uh so a
lot of prior work from
the original stars chronovirus epidemic
um
as well as ongoing work currently uh
shows that
rbd specificity for h2 has a crucial
role in cross-species transmission
so for example you can take bat viruses
which are unable to infect human cells
and if you you know transplant just this
receptor binding domain from a human
virus onto these back viruses
it allows them to then infect human
cells or similarly
adapting sarge covi2 for example to
replicate in mice select specific amino
acid changes
only within the receptor binding domain
also because of the key interaction of
this rbd with ace2
um many potently neutralizing antibodies
that are known to inhibit starch
coronavirus to
replication specifically target the rbd
and prevent its ability to bind to ace2
and so because of these key sort of
evolutionary and immunological
properties
um we wanted to use a standard technique
in the bloom lab
to study protein function specifically
within this rbd
and that technique is called
demutational scanning so mutational
scanning
is a experimental technique to
characterize large numbers of mutations
to a protein of interest
and thereby to learn more about sort of
its biochemistry and evolutionary
properties
the way this approach generally works is
that you create a
library of mutant variants of some
protein of interest and so in this case
rbd we're going to be creating libraries
in which we introduce all possible amino
acid changes across this 200 amino acid
protein
what makes the stimutational scanning
different than just classic biochemistry
is that instead of
then you know characterizing each of
these proteins one by one which
obviously does not scale to these large
numbers
um you actually pool all of these
mutants together and put them
through some sort of experimental assay
in which you can characterize each of
these mutations kind of
individually but in parallel and so in
this case we're going to be
characterizing the effects of all these
mutations
on two properties first of all sort of
the intrinsic folding stability
of the rbd itself as well as its
affinity for human h2 receptor
and so at the end of this experiment
what you end up with is sort of a map
of all possible amino acid changes
across this protein
with regards to their functional effects
and so this is just a snippet of data
i'll be showing you later
um just to kind of preview the way this
data works is each you know row
is a position in the rbd so site one two
three
um and then each uh row sorry columns
are sites each row
is an amino acid change and so for
example this blue square
for introducing arginine at the second
position indicates that this arginine
mutation
um endows for example higher affinity
for h2
whereas a position like this cysteine
here um in the fifth position
um with all these red squares indicate
that all these mutations away from
cysteine
are decreasing whatever functional
property is shown here
so that brings me to kind of the
specifics of what we did
here in this current study um in which
we undertook one of these deviational
scans
for the stars cov2 receptor binding
domain
so i'll start by explaining in a little
bit more detail the specifics of our
experimental assay and then we'll go
through some of the observations we made
from this data
including what it teaches us um a little
bit about the structure function
relationship of how this
receptor binding domain works um we'll
look a little bit at
how these maps of mutational effects can
help us to understand
currently circulating genetic variation
with the massage cov2 pandemic
and then finally i'll touch on what our
maps can teach us about
the epitopes on rbd that are targeted by
neutralizing antibodies
all right so um to kind of do this deep
mutational scan in a high throughput
setup
we turned to a classic system from
protein
engineering and biochemistry which is
beast surface display
so yeast surface display is a technique
that allows you to express
some protein of interest on the cell
surface tethered to individual yeast
cells
and so in this case we have yeast cells
which have
receptor binding domain multivalently
expressed on their cell surface
and when it's there we can do two key
things we can use fluorescent detection
of a tag on the rbd itself
to probe how well expressed the rbd is
on an individual yeast cell surface
and then beyond that we can incubate
with soluble h2
which is also fluorescently tagged so we
can monitor how well any given rdd
variant
binds to ace2 so to kind of show what
this looks like for example if we just
take the stars kobe 2
rbd and express it in its wild type form
in yeast
we can then do a titration series across
an increasing concentration
range of ace2 and we can monitor the
amount of ace2 binding
via flow cytometry and so what you can
see here is that as we increase the
concentration of h2
we get sort of a dose response curve of
h2 labeling of our yeast cells
and so from this relationship between
binding and concentration
we can fit these titration curves um
which are sort of these classic
biochemistry
curves from which we can compute the
dissociation constant or the kd which is
a measurement of the strength
of biochemical interaction between in
this case the wild type stars cov2
rbd and human h2 ligand
so to transition to doing this in more
of a high throughput format
um we first needed to create a mutant
library of stars ob2 so we can
characterize the effects of all these
mutations on this h2 ligand affinity
as well as the expression level of the
rbd and the cell surface
and to do that we constructed duplicate
mutant libraries
using a pcr-based codon mutagenesis
technique
which yielded us libraries of mutant
variants
um we also appended these barcode
sequences downstream
from the individual variant rbd genes
um and then we can put this system uh of
this library of mutant variants into our
yeast display system
but in contrast to what i showed you
before um instead of it just being a
single genotype
each individual yeast cell in the
population will now have
a different rbd variant on its cell
surface
um to kind of allow us to see what's
happening in an individual cell we use
these barcodes then
um what we do is we use long read path
biosequencing to link
individual barcodes to the actual mute
variants that they're associated with
and then what that means is for any
downstream experiment we can just do
short read illumina sequencing with the
barcodes
so for example if we read this yellow
barcode we know it represents this
individual single
mutant genotype
um and then i'm showing you here just
one table
illustrating the kind of coverage that
we get in these libraries
and if you look at the second column you
can see that in each of our duplicate
libraries
we have very high coverage we get
virtually every single possible amino
acid
change the rbd present in our libraries
i think we're missing only 15 of the
almost 4 000 different amino acid
changes that are possible to make
within this domain so next we wanted to
kind of do these titrations but in high
throughput
and so what i showed you before once
again was just doing a titration for
sort of an isogenic yeast population
um but as i was alluding to in the last
slide now we have a mixed
library population in which each yeast
cell has a different genotype on its
cell surface
and so if we look at this great dose
response curve here we no longer have
just a single response curve because
each genotype in the library is sort of
responding to
the ace2 labeling concentration um on
its own sort of
dissociation constant driven saturation
curve
and so rather than just monitoring
fluorescence via full cytometry
what we do for the library experiment
now is we use fluorescence activated
cell sorting
or facts which is a flow cytometry based
method that allows you to not only read
out fluorescence but also separate cells
on the basis of their porcelain signal
and so what we can do is that each of
these h2 concentrations
actually sort the cells into these four
bins illustrated by the dotted lines
and then we use aluminum sequencing to
read out which
use genotype is found in each of these
bins across each of these phase two
concentrations
and so for example um a genotype like
perhaps the yellow which has
high affinity for h2 will begin to kind
of fall into the bin two
three and four partitions at you know
relatively moderate h2 concentrations
i mean that might be different from a
genotype like the blue genotype which
perhaps
does not bind h2 which might be found in
bin one
across this entire concentration range
and so when we do this sort of you know
facts coupled with deep sequencing what
we end up getting
are these titration curves but for each
individual variant in the library
in parallel or simultaneously so what
i'm showing here on the right are just a
random selection
of genotypes in our library which are
labeled on the top
um and then from this kind of massively
parallel experiment
we have the titration curve for each of
these variants sorted independently
you can see how each genotype is in the
library is able to have its own
kind of variant specific titration curve
from which we can compute this
dissociation constant
and therefore end up with a measurement
of the effect of each amino acid on this
phase two binding affinity
and then as our last sort of
experimental kind of
measurement beyond simply determining
mutation effects on ace2 binding
as i alluded to before we're also
measuring the effects of these mutations
on the rbd expression level which is the
correlate of sort of the folding
stability
of the rbd um and so this is a similar
technique it's facts coupled with
sequencing but instead of doing it
across an entire dose response
range we're just doing it you know one
time at one labeling
of rbd expression levels um so we sort
cells into
bins based off of their level of
labeling for rbd expression level
and then we use sequencing to figure out
you know which genotypes are
you know higher or more highly or more
lowly expressing rbd
on the cell surface all right so that's
the technique
um there's a whole lot of qc that goes
into this and we also did a lot of
validation which i'm not going to get
into today
but i do encourage you to check out the
paper
to see kind of uh the reliability of
these measurements
um but what we end up with are these
heat maps as i showed you have very
small snippets of earlier
um illustrating the effects of all amino
acid changes
at each position in the rbd on these two
biochemical phenotypes
so on the top two panels are all the rbd
sites
sort of annotated by the mutation
effects on expression
that sort of stability metric and then
on the bottom
are all of these mutation effects on the
ace2 binding affinities
and so obviously these are very detailed
maps
and i don't expect you to
necessarily take away too much from
looking at them quickly from a bird's
eye view
but they are a super rich kind of
display of
a lot of important information and so
one
key thing we wanted to achieve with this
project was to make sure that
um any researcher doing who knows what
about sarge ob2
that might be able to leverage this
information um also has the ability to
kind of engage with these heat maps
um and so i'll flash up the link here um
but it's also present in the paper
we made interactive versions of these
heat maps so anybody can
kind of open them up on their own and
gaze at them for
hours and hours just like i did to kind
of emerge with some key insights
but just to kind of give some of this
bird's eye view
i'll focus on a few patterns that we can
see in these heat maps
um so in these heat maps as i said
before red
indicates mutations which are
deleterious for a phenotype such as
stability or binding
and then white indicates mutations that
are neutral and blue are mutations that
enhance that biochemical property and so
kind of as you expect
from just classic protein biochemistry
most mutations do as rbd do indeed
you know destabilize the protein or
inhibit its ability to bind these two
but at the same time we do see many
positions where lots of mutations are
neutral um and perhaps even more
surprisingly there are quite a few
positions
where a lot of blue mutations are
cropping up which is to say mutations
that
would enhance either the stability of
the rbd or even its affinity for human
ace too
um and so we'll revisit some of those
specific mutations a little bit later on
uh beyond that we can also see
heterogeneity and the level of
constraint on different positions across
the rbd
so there's some positions where you know
any mutation is kind of more or less
tolerated the same
whereas some positions are highly
constrained where any mutation away from
the wild type amino acid is deleterious
for function
we can also see that you know if you
kind of squint your eyes the
positions that are kind of constrained
for expression and binding tend to
overlap
um although there are some regions uh
where there's kind of
increasing constraint for expression or
binding individually
so with that sort of bird's eye and view
um we'll move on to talk a little bit
about some more specific
um sort of findings that were
observations we made about
the relationship between sequence
structure and function within the starch
ob2 rbd
so here what i'm doing is um taking this
heat map um sort of the average
mutational tolerance of each position
and mapping it to the structure of the
rdd bound to ace2
and so um here we've annotated a few
different features of the rbd
we've annotated what we're calling the
core rbd which is the central beta sheet
folded core of the protein which is sort
of the scaffold on which this rbm or the
receptor binding motif
sort of loopy region sits uh beyond that
i'm also showing some disulphides in
yellow and then
we're showing the bound ace2 ligand in
dark gray
at the top and so each sphere on the rbd
here is colored by the average
mutational effect
on the stability of the rbd so sort of
as you'd expect
um a lot of the positions that are most
constrained with respect to mutational
effects on stability
are sort of buried in the core of the
protein there are these sort of internal
positions
where if you muck them up with mutation
you end up destabilizing the protein
we can do the same thing coloring these
spheres now by their mutational effects
on binding
and as i pointed out before we see some
overlap many of these kind of
buried core positions are also
constrained with
regards to their effects on binding but
beyond that we can see that many more of
these positions
that cluster up at the interface with h2
are
constrained with respect to binding as
you'd expect
so look at this in a little bit more
detail um i'm showing here now for each
site
the correlation between its sensitivity
to mutation with respect to binding and
expression
and so once again you can see that most
positions sort of follow a general trend
where if they're sensitive
for stability they also lose binding
and then of course you can see there are
some positions where they are not
particularly sensitive with respect
mutation effects on expression
but they are for binding and when we
look at these on the structure
these are indeed these positions that
cluster to the h2 interface
um and sort of interact with these two
hotspot residues on these two these two
licenses
um we actually saw a little bit kind of
more interesting uh pattern in this
regard um taking into the more extreme
where we see that there's actually at
some positions
sort of trade-offs between rotational
effects on stability
and binding so here i'm showing heat
maps
uh focused just on five positions that
illustrate these tradeoffs
and what you can see at each of these
bypositions is that many of the
mutations
on left-hand heat map have deleterious
effects on binding
even though they would have improving
effects on the stability or the
expression of the rbg
so one example of this is glycine 502
where any mutation severely hinders
binding even though many of these polar
amino acids
enhance expression and when you look at
the structure this makes sense
it's glycine 502 on the rvd is in very
very close structural proximity to this
important
beta hairpin on these two and there's
simply just not room
for a side chain to accommodate these
two bindings so even though putting a
side chain here might enhance stability
it just wouldn't work for h2 binding
for these other foresights we saw that
these are hydrophobic residues
that are exposed on the rbd surface and
so exposed hydrophobics are known to
destabilize proteins and contribute to
things like aggregation
so mutating these hydrophobic residues
would enhance expression
but these hydrophobic residues are
important for packing at the east 2
surface which is why they have this
binding specific constraint
all right so this has been focusing
mostly on constraint um but i also did
show you that there are many
kind of other interesting enhancing
mutations with respect to stability and
binding
and so i'm going to focus first on
stabilizing mutations and in particular
we were motivated by this idea that
there are a lot of people who want to
engineer rbd protein to have
certain properties such as
immunogenicity or
stability and these maps might be useful
for that and so here's one example of
the recent preprint
which is using an rvd-based vaccine
where
it displays these rbd proteins on the
surface of nanoparticles
another kind of rbd based tool are these
molecular probes
that people can use to isolate these
cells or antibodies that target
the rbd of um2
and we figured our maps could be useful
in two regards here um
we could be making rbd proteins that are
just better behaved biochemically for
example more stable or highly expressing
but beyond that as we learn more about
for example antibody epitopes
on the rbd our maps could be useful for
resurfacing
these rbd proteins um to for example
hide epitopes where perhaps we don't
want antibody responses
or to make better molecular probes to
isolate specific antibodies
so um to look at this a little bit more
i'm showing once again the map just for
mutational effects on expression
i mean in particular we were compelled
by this one region here kind of
down by amino acids 355 to 385 where we
see many blue mutations the mutations
that enhance stability
and so once again this is of course our
yeast display assay so we did want to
validate whether these
really have a stabilizing effect and so
in collaboration with dan ellis and neil
king
we cloned individual appointments of the
tsar's ob2 rbd
and expressed them in mammalian cells
and they saw that
these individual mutations so individual
single mutations
can enhance the soluble expression of
rbd um up to five-fold
um and then on the bottom plot we see
this is also accompanied by increases in
the thermal stability of the rbd
and so we found it super interesting
that these you know
mutations that we found really have big
improving properties on the general
expression and stability of isolated rbd
protein
and we have some interesting ideas about
why this is the case which anyone's
interested in let's talk about further
beyond that we also notice in our data
that we have many
positions where we knocked in and linked
glycan motifs
so those are nxst mutations which are
shown in boxes
on this heat map and at many of these
knock-ins where we add
s's or t's two positions after an
asparagine um we saw that that would
actually enhance expression
and so um n-link glycan knock-in is a
common way to
resurface you know probes or vaccine
immunogens
and then we have seen a bunch of
positions across the rbd where these
glycans can be tolerated
coming back to now the binding effects
of mutations
we're zooming in now on the heat map
just of positions that are actually at
the h2
interface and sort of in contrast to
many proteins where the key functional
sites are especially constrained
we were actually surprised to see that
there is a lot of mutational flexibility
at these positions at the h2 interface
where many mutations are tolerated
and as i said before there's actually
many mutations that actually enhance
the affinity for base two
we were particularly interested in three
positions that cropped up here 493 498
and 501
where there are many of these strong
affinity enhancing mutations
and when you look at the actual
molecular or atomic interface between
rbd
and h2 these residues are kind of
involved in these networks of polar
contacts with key ace2
residues and so just looking at the
structure alone you might not have been
able to predict
that many of these mutations would be
tolerated or enhanced affinity
particularly because many of these kind
of blue mutations
are actually hydrophobic mutations which
would be removing these polar contacts
entirely
and so i think that shows there's a lot
of both mutational but correspondingly
structural flexibility
in how this interface can be kind of
engineered or rearranged
and that's reflected in the evolutionary
record in which this
interface and this rbd in general is
actually quite variable
among kind of stars related chronovirus
isolates
all right um so next we wanted to know
whether we could use our maps to
understand
more about sort of the evolutionary
forces that are guiding search kobe 2
genetic variation
this current phase of the pandemic and
so this pandemic is
interesting from one regard in that we
have
kind of new genomic technologies that
have really come online and
really change the way that we can
understand genetic variation
in this emerging pandemic and so um i
think currently there's something like
75 000
individual stars kobe 2 genomes that are
available um
and so um back when we did this analysis
in may or something like 35 or 30
000 mutation spike sequences available
um we looked at what variation is
present in these sequences within the
rdd
and in general we see that rbd mutations
are still quite rare
among um sequenced stars cov2 isolates
but beyond that besides just seeing
their frequency we now also have
functional annotations of these
mutations effects
so what i'm showing here is um on the
y-axis the effects of mutations on
binding
and then we bind um mutations by the
number of times they've been observed on
this repository of sequence stars
cov2islets
and so what you can see is that for any
mutation that has been seen
you know more than a handful of times
there's this increasing bias
in what types of mutational effects are
present among implementation sets
so anything you know seen more than six
times has essentially zero effect
on binding and so we see that as
evidence for purifying selection in
which mutations that would decrease
binding
are being selected against and that's
why they're not being seen at high
frequency
among these sequence variants
beyond that as i pointed out to you we
have many affinity enhancing mutations
as well
and so these mutations are indeed
accessible to
the wild type virus you know they can be
accessed by single nucleotide mutations
um but they're not being fixed or even
seen
in natural stars ob2 circulating strains
and so we thought that was interesting
given that these mutations are available
but not being seen
we take that as um evidence that perhaps
there's not any selective pressure for
higher affinity for ace ii which is to
say perhaps
you know the virus is already sorted in
that goldilocks sweet spot for the
degree of affinity that it has for human
ace ii
um kind of consistent with this idea
that there aren't really strong
phenotypic consequences of mutations
that are currently circulating in the
rbd
um we did look at sort of the most
prevalent mutations
um in sequence stars cody two isolates
and so the top five prevalent mutations
are shown here
um and you can see once again that um
we're really not seeing any strong
biochemical consequences
for these mutations with respect to our
phenotypes of phase two binding
and expression with just the one
exception being the 367f mutation uh
which we do ascribe a large stability
enhancing effect
and this was indeed one of the mutations
that we validated
in the purified rdds and so we don't
know what the consequence of that is
for the actual virus but i do think that
it's quite interesting to note
um and perhaps it's worth following up
on
and then of course um i think you know
it feels like it's been a really long
time but it seems like we're actually
probably still in quite an early phase
of this pandemic at least from the
perspective of the virus and its
evolutionary dynamics
um and so as this virus continues to
circulate in the population
and begin to encounter things like
engine pressure um
and you know a less wide availability of
sustainable hosts
um it'll be interesting to see or
continue to surveil mutations that are
arising
um in the context of these maps
all right um and then last um i'll talk
about what our maps might be able to
teach us about antibody epitopes within
the rbd
so as i mentioned at the beginning the
rbd is a common target of
antibodies that neutralize stars cov2
um and these antibodies are just showing
a structural alignment of several of
them
sort of decorate a bunch of different
surfaces on the rbd
um and related to this question about
how it might evolve over time
one super important question that we
don't really know much about yet
um is whether this type of virus or
whether this virus will be able to
do this type of evolution similar to how
flu evolves
um to sort of turn over its antigenic
determinants over time
or whether it will be more sort of
antigenically stable such as a virus
like measles um so to begin to get some
insight into that
we were motivated by a paper that came
out also during the summer
which passages viruses in the presence
of monoclonal antibodies
and then sequenced to see what types of
mutations it was fixing
to escape these neutralizing antibodies
that they were prone to
and so even though these antibodies
target the regions that surround these
kind of mutationally constrained
contacts
phase two the sites at which the
antibody escape mutations were actually
accruing in um this study uh we're kind
of finding the mutationally tolerant
residues in this otherwise constrained
region
and the specific mutations that we're
fixing um shown on the right
as you'd expect have sort of biased more
neutral effects on h2 binding infinity
obviously because if you need a mutation
to escape an antibody but you also lose
h2 binding
the virus wouldn't be able to tolerate
that so to look at that in a little more
detail
i'm showing our kind of mutational
constraint
coloring on the surface representation
of the rdd
and then we can outline residues that
participate in epitopes or interaction
interfaces
and so for reference um the black
outlines in this image here
um illustrate which residues um contact
base ii and as i showed before these are
quite patiently constrained
and then we can show different
antibodies that target the rbd
and sort of the regions that they
interact with and so on the top you can
see many antibodies sort of target
one or two of the same patches that
interact with phase two
um although they also sort of extend
their structural interfaces
to other less constrained regions and so
this suggests that there are multiple
individual epitopes that can be targeted
that overlap
these constrained h2 contact positions
but at the same time
it might be beneficial to achieve better
so-called epitope focusing on
specifically the very constrained
positions
that make these exact h2 contacts
on the bottom we can see a little bit
more distant epitopes in this core rbd
which are constrained with respect to
mutational effects on expression
and so overall this kind of structural
mapping highlights the presence of
multiple kind of mutationally
constrained patches on the rbd surface
and it might be important to consider
the ability of for example
vaccine-induced immunity
to elicit antibodies to multiple of
these patches simultaneously
to perhaps prevent the ability of virus
to
evolve to evade antibody based immunity
finally we also did note there was one
surface um
or one patch on the surface where we
don't know of any antibodies yet that
have been structurally mapped
but does show high intrinsic mutational
constraint so this patch is sort of
centered around this residue
um e465 and so we think it's interesting
to kind of guess whether there will
eventually be antibodies that target
this region
and whether this might be a sort of
mutationally intolerant
or constrained region that can't evade
such antibodies
all right so i think that's everything i
want to talk about today um like i said
there are a lot more details in the
paper that i couldn't get into
um but i wanted to show some of the
early observations we've made from this
sort of mapping of additional effects on
the search kobe 2 rbd
um with that i wanted to thank um once
again all the people who contributed to
this work
as well as the funding and once again
emphasized that if anybody is doing work
on the sarge code v2 rbd um and thinks
that these maps of mutational effects
could be
helpful um i really encourage you to
check them out and
please don't hesitate to reach out to us
we would love to help anybody doing
anything
to be able to take advantage of this
resource that we generated
thank you very much